What's up everybody!
This is Emil from Pongfinity.
So I was recently at the World Championships
that was held in Düsseldorf, Germany.
I was invited there by the International Table
Tennis Federation, the ITTF, who wanted me
to make some trick shot videos with some of
the world's best players at the World Championships.
So, well, of course I went there, I had a
great time filming with the players there
and I think the videos turned out to be really
nice.
I have actually now made a compilation out
of the best trick shots we filmed there and
I think it's really nice and I'll show it
to you now.
Hope you enjoy!
So that was the video, it was a lot of fun
making it!
Let me know in the comments below whose trick
shot do you think was the best one!
I still have to say about the event itself,
the World Championships, that was absolutely
amazing event, everything was so well organized
there and the venue looked incredible.
I actually have a picture to show you, here's
how it looked like from inside.
There were four tables in the main hall and
there were seats for 7000 or 8000 people.
The atmosphere in the hall was awesome especially
during the last 3 or 4 days when it was completely
sold out.
As you might know, eventually most of the
medals went to the Chinese players.
In the Women's singles we saw Ding Ning win
her 3rd World Championship title meanwhile
in the Men's Singles Ma Long took his 2nd
World Championship title.
Here's actually a picture with Ma Long after
the exhausting final.
I wasn't this time able to film any trick
shots with him, but maybe some time in the
future, who knows, we'll see :)
But yeah, being at the World Championships
and watch some of the world's best players
compete there and also film some videos with
them afterwards was an incredible experience
and I just want to say huge thanks to the
ITTF for making that all possible.
But I think this was all for this week's video,
if you enjoyed it please leave it a thumbs
up below, and make sure to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already!
Until next time!